now every country has races but as of is
a battalion that was integrated into the
Ukrainian Army and and formally became
their National Guard so the Ukrainian
National Guard is the azov Battalion as
of our Nazis this is not in dispute this
is not a opinion this is a matter of
fact I for 10 years ran the world's
first and leading counter-extremism
organization it was our job to brief
Prime Ministers and presidents on who is
an extremist I have met in that Pursuit
uh George Bush Tony Blair David Cameron
more heads of state than I can imagine
one-on-one talking like this I am
telling you as of our Nazis this is not
in uh dispute it's a fact they have not
seen Insignia and yet we're sending
weapons and funds to Nazis who are
integrated into the Ukrainian Army
that's like saying that because we
wanted to get rid of Assad we're going
to fund Isis